l'un de vos dessins suscite actuellement
de violentes réactions sur les réseaux
sociaux va le voir ce dessin dans un
article de nos confrères de libération
dessin que vous aviez publié dans le
journal L'Union oui on y voit le petit
Elan ce petit garçon syrien d'origine
curde échoué sur une plage de Turquie
avec ce texte c'est la rentrée vous
dites c'est un dessin poétique
symbolique oui parce que cette semaine
c'est la semaine du maronier de la
rentrée on nous filme l'angoisse des
parents des choses très futiles et à ce
moment au même moment
et bien c'est l'exode l'exode que nous
avons connu en 40 c'est la guerre qui
pousse des et donc je me suis dit mais
notre quotidien il est assez futile
finalement et il fallait rendre hommage
à cet enfant surtout cet enfant c'est
c'est c'est notre c'est le nôtre c'est
c'est l'enfant qu'on amène à l'école
voilà et effectivement euh mais ça
provoqu des des commentaires très
violents d'abord beaucoup d'internautes
vous ont pris pour Charlie Hebdo et puis
on clairement dit que vous alliez trop
loin sur Twitter un utilisateur a même
écrit Charlie Hebdo je crois que mort ne
vous fait pas peur vous voulez que
d'autres malades comme lesquachi
reviennent mais je crois que le 7
janvier a a fait imploser le le la
dimension du dessin de presse un dessin
de presse c'est quelque chose qui peut
faire réfléchir c'est aussi un sourire
ici c'est un dessin hommage donc les
gens je crois on ont redécouvert après
le 7 janvier le dessin de presse mais
non plus les codes culturels et donc pas
de caricature sans culture